[Music]
i'm joe navarro i'm a body language
expert and today i'm going to be
reviewing my own body language
[Music]
so in may of 2019
i was looking at body language for wired
now we're going to be looking at my body
language during that same time period
most of my career i spent within the
national security division a lot of it
had to do with looking at specific
targets and then it was about well how
do we get in their heads and how do we
neutralize them so there were some
questions about my interlaced hands uh
during this initial video
and for me that's just one of those
comfort behaviors that i use to
help myself obviously i'm not in front
of the camera all the time so it does
provide a little bit of psychological
discomfort so oftentimes
you'll see me with interlaced hands and
and many people do that and it's just
that it's a comforting behavior i find
it very useful and if you've ever
wondered what to do when you're sitting
in a meeting and don't know what to do
with your hands just interlace your
fingers it's better than having your
hands flat or your hands disappear
totally from the table
we may think we're very sophisticated
but in fact we are never
in a state where we're not transmitting
information oh wait wait wait go go back
because i did something really weird my
elbows came in and my hands went out and
i realized
that uh when i'm uncomfortable i i do
things that actually reflect that now
you've probably seen me grab my whole my
hands together multiple times that's
dealing with insecurity
but here at this moment what you see is
i bring my elbows close to the body
and my hands come together here
and what i'm in essence doing is being
less territorial
and as i evaluate myself i'm saying to
myself okay this is something you
shouldn't do even if it was just
momentary
that my gestures
should be fluid they should be out here
that by self-restraining myself i'm
actually taking away from the message
and this is one of the advantages of
watching a video is that you can see
yourself make this mistake and say you
know what i'm going to be careful next
time to make sure that i don't do it
even if it's just
momentarily
in my 25 years in the fbi
it was a rarity
that a person didn't eventually uh
reveal
what i needed to know
so as i'm looking at the video
and i'm
having a
a good conversation with myself
and i realize how often my leg shakes
and this is a comment that uh
has been made
i've been made aware of several times
and i tend to bounce my leg or my foot
tends to shake
and i do that
subconsciously i think it helps me to
relax i think it helps me to to to deal
with stress i've
done it all my life why are we seeing it
here a person that lives in in florida
he all of a sudden is now in new york
city
in a strange environment surrounded by
at least 10 or 15 people that i've never
met before and that creates anxiety and
how do we deal with anxiety we deal with
them through the use of pacifiers
the hand touching the hand uh ringing
the shaking
legs all contribute to that process if
it stands out and people can notice it
it can be
very distracting so
it's one of those things that i'm going
to be paying attention to from now on
so i just noticed one other small
behavior and it's it's a small gesture
and that is that i'm pulling down on my
jacket this is called a preening
behavior
and we do that for a couple of reasons
you know some people do it because um
they want to fix themselves right they
want to look right i remember
as an fbi agent we always preened
ourselves fix our jackets and our ties
before the jury came in into the room i
think i was doing the same here because
i was very conscious of how my suit was
looking in front of the the camera
because they kept saying make sure you
pull down so the the back of your
of your suit doesn't uh scrunch upwards
the other reason
that we sometimes preen ourselves is
because we are physically touching our
bodies and in doing so the texture of
the material the coldness of the
material in this case here
also helps to
to soothe us in the same way that a
small child will hang on to a blanket or
a teddy bear or something
that touch helps to to calm us we never
really outgrow that even as
adults
we will always
be touching things
um to help us uh to calm down and in my
case
uh obviously to me i can well see that
there was a high degree of nervousness
there and and that's how i was dealing
with it
you as an audience and even me right now
as i'm watching this i i realize i have
forgotten all this activity that that's
going on and i have to be mindful of
what i'm going to say how i say it and
what's next oftentimes we look at a
video
we see an interview and we forget
how many dozens of people were behind
that camera
and that everything that is behind the
camera and everything that happened that
day
prior to that camera turning on
affects that person in a moment in time
the best that we can do is appreciate
what's said how it's said and then maybe
we can dig a little deeper but we
shouldn't come to too many conclusions
just based on a video and what an
eye-opener for me as i'm
watching myself here and i realize
that there were three cameras and 15
people at that moment looking at me and
how intimidated i actually felt
i'm a high-end introvert so watching
myself
being in front of a group is very very
uh difficult but i think it's something
that we can now with iphones and and
other
you know smartphones it's easy to do
to uh watch ourselves even if it's just
for a few minutes and say boy how can i
improve on on that and so i think it's a
it's a useful tool
you